sur leur tapis colorés ils enchaînent la
posture du chien pète en bas celle du
cobra voire du guerrier ceux que l'on
surnomme les yogis ses adeptes du yoga
célèbre aujourd'hui cette pratique
traditionnelle indienne qui pour
plusieurs représente bien plus qu'un
exercice physique et spirituelle on ne
peut pas construire beaucoup d'hôpitaux
ou de dispensaires donc si on fait du
yoga tous les jours c'est très simple
pour tout le pays
raconte cette professeure de yoga
prenant part à un rassemblement dans le
nord de l'inde
même le premier ministre n'a rennes
drame audi s'est prêté à l'exercice
lui qui depuis son élection en 2014 fait
la promotion de la culture ancienne de
l'inde à l'origine de la résolution de
l'organisation des nations unies
instituant le 21 juin comme journée
internationale du yoga il a déclaré que
cette pratique a désormais une influence
positive sur des millions de vies à
travers le monde
et l'engouement international est bien
réelle de washington à amsterdam
des milliers de sessions collectives
étaient organisées aujourd'hui pieds nus
et les yeux fermés les détenus de cette
prison de new delhi apprennent aussi les
rudiments du yoga des postures appelé à
sa masse comme sort et au progrès nous
pensons que le yoga peut aider les
détenus aux prises avec des problèmes de
santé mentale et de dépression dit le
directeur
une façon de récupérer en quelque sorte
leur liberté ici jacques andré
charbonneau radio canada montréal